you
fingers crossed that it doesn't crash
please go smooth
Tehan started streaming nice
he started streaming okay okay okay here
we go fingers crossed fingers crossed go
smooth good luck
good luck good luck need a lot of luck
three-two-one streamer team battle
oh there we go okay it started Zuber and
I don't know we don't have information
on which team Zuber is a part of okay
just preparing to have this square for
my bishop I'm going to try to establish
a duo uh-huh let's come all the way back
it's tempted to go here but if I do this
taketake I'll do this square is very
weakened so I want to be a bit delicate
with my a pawn who
okay so thinking more about trying to
get to this square if I can get rid of
the dark square Bishop s' may play d4
double pawns I'm going to try for this
we're gonna be coming at me here where
does my queen belong I'll stay here
there may be some sacrifices soon I
could could experience some some
pressure on the F file okay this bishop
I need to I need to stay right here
surprise the night went in right away
let's play b5
this pond I'm trying to trying to
control this this night here sacrifice
may be nearby
this night was over here could be a big
problem okay I didn't
oh okay that's that's very very strong
yeah that makes me think I should have
played c5 hmm
yeah this this is getting broken down
now I'm in some hot water I think
alright let's start with this
I'm banking on our sum
here whoo
I have to play night here
you have to try night here
and try it this night can be dislodged
very soon
and this may be that
take care
Queen takes our knight takes okay
it takes here
let's check but this is this is going to
be an issue
this
down below - time
let's go here
defending the night this is a very
uncomfortable pin
trial
hm
yeah I'm gonna have to try and get I
have to give up peace here got to get
out of that pin so what do I got two
pawns for the piece two pawns for a
bishop this guy can go to though
try and stay active with my clean
take what the nail
my back rank as well not going well
this guy could file I see no reason not
to take this it's opens up a big square
for this piece too
centralise bishop
check
bring a queen exchange
I guess
I don't I don't like have
go for that but
17 seconds
hmm
you know that ponds toast try to get to
the seventh
second
I don't like that my kings on a light
square
night can't go here
you
and I could just give a check
19 seconds not good
I should've went to
yeah I should probably resign no time
and positions gun holy cow look at all
the streamers oh well I didn't update
that in a while
yeah there's a lot of streamers okay
I didn't even have a chance to look at
look at the tournament standings
now who this player is representing
okay
let's try to force this issue trying to
get rid of that guy
take with the Queen I guess we'll take
with the Queen
put pressure on b7
g3 h4r now let's go a g3 h4
I'm looking at the g5 square
Bishop their night there let's get the
King up first okay I don't mind seeing
it close a little bit
make sure my bishop can be exchanged at
this stage I take with the pond I'm kind
of recalling the one
the one game I covered recently with
Lila some Queen sacrifice on f6
an opportunity to break things up here
with g6 I think is worthwhile this
square right here is basically what I
want to try to get to
it's not even any gut though this night
covers this square very well they're
still gonna put him there and I could
glue them in with f4
I sure would like to maybe put pressure
on g6 but I don't I don't see how I
could do that
and be some play over here pressure on a
three
clean here to have to defend
who t bring this guy
over here now let's take I'm afraid of
b3 and I'm creating a passed pawn so
back rank mates they have to be a bit
careful about
um let's go here I thought about this
I have this score covered I was thinking
it for a little bit the clink ago to
AIDS free so I have a more active rook
there could be some sacrifices here
I want to get my queen working
let's let's tie the Queen down first
I could take and then take here is that
going to be enough
hmm I'm I want to I want to keep this
around now I'm threatening now I'm
threatening some some tricks here take
stakes and then here in the end with the
fork
do I still have a
let's keep some pressure here the knight
can't move
I think next I'm able to take oh no no
if the rook steps up I have this rook to
b8 so I think I'm winning though
they're their back foot here
you
they're in the tank
okay let's get the clean
you
and I see no reason to
and then we could finally do this trick
taking the night
and it should be very clean from here
and resign or play on playing it out
maybe some strategy
so it's a whole different world these
team battles
could be some strategies
with playing playing the games out I got
a watch for a sneaky pawn move
try to finish fast try and get another
game in they got matin ex I should have
double-checked that this was a move this
pod was blocked but this one that was
their only illegal move okay back to
tournament let's go Oh what do we got
whoa
Edie we already have 91 points so this
is going to change very quickly
currently sixth place for the team 91
okay
don't know who this players representing
team team black again let's go it go at
these six we have an Enzo
castle
um I'm going to damage the structure
right now let's just go right into
trying to build in the center
let's get this pawn contributing I don't
want to ever see this I'm basically
trying to play against this Bishop and
he think that bishops out of play now
of time
could play this this is a critical move
let's see
f 3 or not okay f4 ok I for I can't take
because a bishop takes bishop so I want
to make sure this doesn't happen okay so
now here here I'm going to go with this
with the idea that if the Queen moves to
attack it I could play here focusing on
this and defending h4 it's important I
have my queen here to defend
so it's pretty locked I have control
over the key pawn breaks this guy here
doesn't bother me this push or capture
doesn't really benefit
um
doesn't benefit white by doing anything
with this pawn where does my knight go
when I say let's go here eventually I
want to maneuver my knight I think to
this square not sure step up
b7 is gonna be a target
oh the knight okay I did not even
consider that that was uh that that was
a move do not want this diagonal to open
up so that's why I'm never really going
to touch that let's go here putting a
lot of pressure on my Queen side I'm not
used to seeing this approach
I don't know why I'm on the B file
anymore there isn't this rook pressure
anymore let me step up
maybe hinting at a sacrifice keeping the
Queen tied to c4 as well okay a capture
we take with the pawn hmm okay I'm going
to be losing him some material they
could take here actually
hmm okay chop-chop
rook takes rook in between her and then
you pull a piece away from this okay
that move Queen takes could still do
this trick maybe I should have played b6
much sooner slight time edge this
bishops kind of a dummy unless there's
some sacrifice working here okay
opportunity to play b6 if I play b6 then
there's going to be doubled up and
triple enough I may not be able to get
out of a pin they have to part ways with
this pawn I have to get out of any
potential pin along the D file
and maybe try to stare at this light
square they they don't have that light
square bishop anymore this is this is a
good pivot square okay they have an
in-betweener okay or am i clean didn't
see that that was a move all right I
guess I'm gonna part ways with another
pawn it's not the most important pawn
right here this is the most important if
both of these go this guy's gonna fly
kick that night away that's a strong
move
I have this square covered
maybe I'd do something active Queen a4
why not clean a4 I really in the tank
there
am i capturing first then let's go here
oh the rook is defended oh I have bishop
check oh oh that was a big miss oh no
God do time burners
whoa that was a huge mess a huge mess
ah oh man that was a huge mess new
something felt wrong um I don't know I
don't know I don't know what to do
what about Queenie or Queen here I don't
have a queen haha okay
uh yeah that night is kind of pesky mm
that's tough to time burn had a passer
ah
you dummy woody okay just back to Turin
I gotta get back in there oh why did I
move my Queen like that oh man ah Bishop
takes and the rook was defended I wasn't
even seeing that the knight defended the
rook there okay we got the white fox
for the white fox
I wished Oh
okay and I once more didn't even a check
to see where the where the team is at
yet right after that game
barely back lucky to get a point
okay
you
you
all right let's go here
I don't know I was ready to be kicked
here and then there's night here hunting
my LightScribe bishop down so i would
prefer to a light square bishop exchange
Queen b6 is is on the radar here right
now let me maybe challenge this guy
first that Bishop is very strong it's
the bad bishop but it's a very active
bad bishop
okay we're gonna have some minor pieces
come off try to one day maybe take
advantage of
these weaknesses there are three holes
the clay in the center
to put this rook here
I'm still thinking about that miss
bishop f8
should have played b6 in that game much
much sooner
let's centralize
whoo okay okay light square bishop
exchange first
and then take care okay I'm winning upon
watch out for any discoveries don't get
hit with a discovery just inch over be
very careful with your clean
okay these tournaments I could already
tell are gonna be too fun okay I should
have this one
okay I could do it in a couple ways
take care
I could have captured as well and then
captured here Queen takes Queen I take
the rook first with check and then
recapture
okay we are upper oh actually I'm up to
rooks
it's defended okay they resign where we
are
215
2:15
team rating whoo okay California
Dreaming a berserk game
do it it's for the team play this one
like it's a bullet game
but just a little bit more time as all
play it like it's bullet
maybe we get a three in there for for
the team
I don't care about GG puns
I don't care about double deaf bones
either
okay King step up
feel like I just want to take that night
yeah he's just gonna be annoying to me
um let's go here Queens off
let's go here nice and cozy nice and
cozy
minority attack
let's go here
hmm
let's try this
and this
Bishop has that square
you could try for me
hmm
coin exchange 52 seconds
hmm prepare to double they're not a good
position it can test the h-file
my knight could do better
rook h3 is a threat
let's go here maybe I win the Queen
think I'm close to winning the Queen yes
Queen here I have this Queen back here I
have this
yes they have to part ways with the
clean put my night here clock
be very careful
or h2
I feel very comfortable playing that
bullet
I can't move fast as fast as I would
like
take care with check
let's get pushing here
you
you
no stalemates just dislike say that that
was almost stalemate okay let's
let's not lose all your bonds
okay come on
no stalemates
okay back to tournament where are we at
255 look how quickly these change this
is awesome okay I have no idea how all
the other players are doing for Team
chess network but uh yeah it shifts
quite a bit that's so cool
all right
maybe six
how to defend b2
let's just keep out a piece from b5
all right um can I still play this no no
here Queen takes Queen takes pawn
there's night see to saving the night
defending the rook I could get back here
later like right now
since I was provoked
I guess we'll take
I will take here No
you
yeah I'm just gonna keep it as is this
night I don't know
I don't want eventual pressure against
b7 I think I enjoy
a slight pull here without going in for
some pond grab
okay I'll take this rook is here III
thought about this actually for a moment
I push Knight takes Knight follows let's
just centralize for right now maybe this
is nearby
Knight takes Knight now this night we'll
be hanging in the end yeah let's take
with the Queen run this now Queens very
active good Pond Center let's do
something active
well rook here is controlling the pawn
breaks preparing to double
that now keep thinking I'm gonna miss
something have that bit that Queen move
that I made earlier to 2a4 oh it's still
on my mind
94 pile-up on c3
protecting b4 that's a good move let's
put the knight in there's also a new
spot for my bishop
defend this night has to go back to e to
once let's open it up a little bit on
the queenside threatening to take twice
here maybe now my queen would be hit
let's not lose the Queen again on a four
okay maybe I should just run away from
that a Foursquare huh sneak in a flight
square I have checks let's keep this in
mind our bishop here I ship there why
don't I go Bishop there keep keep
putting on the pressure on c3 I gave up
too soon on this uh c3 pressure they
could play this maybe the bishops
unprotected I should have played there
okay let's let's do this now three
attackers three defenders night there I
could take my take how to take in that
direction let's go here maybe some
some what what's that move take here
right maybe that was a slip
I might have been a slip back off I mean
here wrote here I could push it away
let's do that
you know oh let's go with rook takes
rook because I have a passed pawn now
connected
and let's put the Queen right here okay
I have a trick which pawn do I want I'm
gonna go at the center one that's check
as well now let's take care okay
let's just give another check on push I
could take here with check at the
Queen's off I guess we'll go in for this
now
the rook check and then push just going
to hide my rook put it on a protected
square and then push through
on down this tournament is flying by a
minute a minute 30 now we're 30 I
already a half hour it's gone by
we should have may in here here here
back determine okay where we at here 314
314 314 team points okay is this um this
maybe if I could get this one here so we
get a 4 okay let's stay focused here
take let's challenge this pawn right
away take um let's go here take with the
bishop let's just rule out any Greek
gift stuff with Knight jumping here try
to keep this a night out of e5 can I get
in b6 b6 Bishop b7 em okay they're not
going for that I could have been
critical let's just throw this in maybe
make him feel a little uncomfortable
let's get to the center ready to push
but the thing is now that the rook is
here I'd have night before hey they're
still they're allowing night before um
can I get a little bit more there's not
they're not many squares for this rook
and take this pond
nice who take the pawn now art the
bishop
the bishop
hmm
with the Queen here I'm fearful of this
break huh yeah this is actually quite
scary maybe was best this actually okay
now this is this is concerning me some
okay I may need to prepare for some 'if
I've at some point okay this is this is
tough this is tough
try to get b5 and I'm Way behind on the
clock
will there be this break
think it's there
this was too this was too slow
this is trouble with this idea
Bishop is okay and they I think they
should have captured my dark square
bishop
thing I want to take this guy right now
you
b5 I have f6 to blunt this diagonal
not at least there isn't something
that's unprotected I'm trying to grant
my bishop access or even Queen to this
square even even at the cost of even
though I give up a passed pawn to my
opponent okay let's be careful
thank f6 they have to play off six
they're ready to meet this capture with
the push threatening me
so let's see maybe even on this I could
take here I made me I have many
different options they're coming back so
I'm on the clock
okay now I should take if I can maintain
peace here this Bishop isn't really
applying I have the better bishop in
this opposite color Bishop position
let's offer a queen exchange
yeah this bishop is fantastic on d5
threatening mate threatening the Queen
if you want to keep the Queen's on the
Queen has to go back to f1
okay this is this is a good advantage
for black now to activate the rooks
activate the King do something over here
that pawn is attacked
let's step up like this cover my base
points this guy is ready to roll let's
go here
stop Bishop b4
the B and C files are opened I control
one of them at the moment looking for
the other one as well
pressure here so this rook has a
responsibility let's get active
King of seven I want
stay on light squares
now let's continue
what about this as well
let's do that
let's expand over here
and yeah I want to control some dark
squares
um how do you win this let's go here
let's go here first
let's go here a little bit scared
raka
this was silly
okay get one of them on the seventh I
guess I was just blooded rook oh man
pressure here to neutralize that
now I have this now that they they were
oh they dropped their bishop
here here's the way
got some windmill action okay they
resigned back to tournament got a four
there 353
is where okay Lochner
whoa a quick resigner I love quick
resign errs is that another four
okay okay
there's so much to look at oh I want I
want to I'm enjoying playing but I also
want to like be a spectator of like all
his action there's a lot of action look
at berserk only probably going berserk
only okay this this could be a big
problem now
this bishop is extra excited about being
on this diagonal
I'm going to preserve my structure on
the queenside and maneuver over here
unlike that was it the second game I
played in this tournament
so this could be a problem that's this
early decision to play here I have an
open H file so I'm bit hesitant to
Castle too soon as this would demote the
rook
so
um I'm anticipating eventual c-5 so
let's just kind of make this Universal
move c3 Queen there um let's let's go in
for this but maybe I could have done
that instead of c3 maybe maybe it was
more to the point offering a queen
exchange okay I guess we're gonna go in
for a queen exchange if they avoided the
Queen exchange I would really wouldn't
be too concerned that my king was in the
center with the Queen's on the board
there's no other piece that's working
with their queen
so I have this nice pawn break in my
back pocket but at the moment it can be
met with h5 nice time edge
you
Wow they're really in the tank
doesn't show don't know who this players
representing they're really in the tank
a minute edge I have they might have a
connection issue comcast gambit no
comcast gambit there they're locked in
there okay they were it's it's an
uncomfortable move to make I'm gonna go
here to undal take with the knight the
bishop the bishop the bishop wasn't
doing anything
I have rook here
let's do this
let's get active here
not just to any square I want to okay my
rook is under fire let's back off to
this square I have to be careful of a
fork here
let's stay here we're gonna get a bunch
of exchanges hmm
both rooks are gonna come off
let's try this f6 maybe good yeah okay
let's back off that night controls this
square so that's why both rooks could
come off they're ready to challenge me
okay so now I want to get rid of this
Knight
I don't like how these last few moves
I think they benefited my opponent these
last few moves
however upon in Black's house so maybe I
could work with that if this guy ever
Falls this guy is extra fast just three
steps to touchdown land
I can't take twice I'm actually quite
happy to see that move
throwing this check and wine up and now
I think I am
definitely better here oh I I could have
considered capturing here because there
isn't a Bishop c5 move okay still have
this under control that pawn is not
threatened let's get this majority going
right three versus two
yeah let's keep going with it
I'm edged as well there's a pin here
maybe getting one rock off is a good
idea maybe this let's stop rook here
okay let's let's play on this side of
the board let's get this one work off
and then target these guys
hmm
you
yeah let's get one rack off
okay
exchange take this pawn now
now step up meeting this with this okay
Bishop there now let's look for this
pawn
actually I don't want to see this and
then a push hey bishop there drops this
poem
just back off
to push here
in here let's keep the Kings sealed but
be careful of stalemates and rook here
taking this check good time edge they
resigned back to Turman who okay to 219
currently in seventh 219 236 okay eel AB
let's try an e for a game I don't even
know how many how many points I have
let's go at c3
I should have played that mm-hmm okay
let's get in the center
this go on an Evo
okay um you know take with the pun I
take with the pun
I have a shattered queenside but some
some ideas some ideas for a quick mate
and Bishop here seems very sensible rook
here defend the bishop discoveries
centralized
yeah let's centralize hmm about Queen
here this pond could fall very easily do
I care about that how are they defending
f7 I have to take my knight but then
they are severely weakened on the dark
squares I'm taking it the bishop take
with the Queen the Queen will be
challenged let's see I want the bishop
here
bishop here queen here so oh oh that's
that's a very sneaky move
it takes they're going to thwart my
attack
now I'm keeping the queen's own can't
take here because of this and need the
assistance of this pawn no let's get in
position right now bishop there now this
queen is restricted the
can't go here now rook takes pawn is a
threat maybe some defense
way behind on the clock
okay my queen needs to go somewhere else
the rook is uh hmm okay
vulnerable to
and they throw in a check immediately
offering a clean exchange do not like
that I still want to keep the Queens on
the Queen is so active so active rookie
to trying flusher out of there
get out
don't want to draw
or maybe this sacrifice yes it's got to
be the right thing to do
get this guy rolling keep going again
get here clean here Queen here Queen on
d8
okay I think this was necessary I'm
threatening mate yes double check mate
who they were so active there okay where
are we at 452 453 471 510 543
let's keep going so tough
Knight f6
I guess see six
quick see 596 maybe we get in b5 I'll
copy favor right now I guess I'm staying
a bit flexible at this point I'm not
sure why I'm doing like this but they
could have maybe played that a little
bit sooner
space well let's go here I was thinking
about c4
question
how annoying is the pin annoying enough
they could they could maybe capture here
capture here maybe I'm taking with the
pawn
let's run it like this
okay
he five okay my night is under fire
come back
hmm surprise that they gave that up
that night was very strong
okay my knight is there covering
in stage seven mm-hmm for now
let's go here my king is prepared to run
there are variations where I could
allow the check
let's try for a break over here get my
bish I want to just exchange my bishop
off for anything
let's do it
okay Queen tell ty
miss that move
I missed that move
they're up a pond or no maybe maybe I am
threatening this I'm might have got a
little lucky here or as c4 maybe the the
move taking like this I have a skewer
I'm still down upon even on the clock
hmm okay I'm going to go for this first
right I have this cupboard
then take here
Queen should step over to defend you
know something that defends before there
it is take here
take on b5 and then Roque for
okay for
93 to defend
with my night
maybe this
my rook is unprotected unprotected okay
I gotta back off
know what forward
let's back off
it's a good move
hmm
I feel like my queen needs to inch over
here they still have a lot of pressure
full compensation full compensation here
for white knight here is strong maybe
you know I have a fork knight here maybe
I drop back I don't want a lot Bishop
takes Knight yes we just fall back might
be some sacrifices here if the brook
leaves I have some checks so and the
King doesn't have this square just yet
if the King has to play here could be
trouble that Knight is so strong
clean here clean here my light squares
are so so much in trouble clean here
rook takes pawn
hmm
slight edge on the clock
tense
connected passers
huh
okay I didn't even see that that was a
defense
how do I get like rid of that night what
do I do
I don't know what to do let's come over
here try to get to the back rank
you
right here on opposite
the king at least
trying to make their King feel bit
uncomfortable one way or the other the
rook is pinned
and it like Queen takes Knight though
it's going back
rook here one of these two is pinned oh
I could take here
there's no truck takes night it's in a
pin it's a big miss now I could just
clog it up I'm up a rook and now we're
gonna have this simplify
here step over with my king get my king
over here stopping these pawns my time
a mouse lip
ok.well stalemates
no stalemates
and we got mate who okay Wow
that was a really fast pairing really
fast let's go with d4
Hawkins defense
no idea where
team members are at
okay let's just break a pin
hmm we'll go here
take with the Queen
okay let's push this night back
and
it's actually push now e6 is
so easy
the puns will end up split okay let's go
here there's our very difficult now I
think for black
tough to complete development I mean I
guess you maybe try to fianchetto yes
take here King takes check I don't quite
have enough
have enough pieces around too
that kind of magic happen I actually I
think I like having my night here
and then let's let's just go to the most
active square I'm opposite few pieces
yeah one night is challenged let's sneak
in the flight square I guess here
can't challenge the knight again in the
end east seven would fall so this stuff
in the end I get a t7 so they may try to
address my bishop but I'll try to be a
pest
do some light square weaknesses
preparing this advance huh
let's go here anticipating this I could
go here in the nights lost
my nights unprotected but I could
recapture like this the night was also
pinned yeah let's go let's actually go
here the Queen may be trying to sneak
away out of off of this d-file
night here maybe just back up
you
huh
you
oh let's see
yeah let's just make a quick move whoa
didn't see that they could
do that okay let's go here and then here
defense attack pressure on e7 that move
is the bishop lost the
should be lost because of this among the
rook and threatening f4 and it has no
squares also if it moves I have Queen e6
check who knows what that may net me
okay so they're just that's probably the
better better move but actually let me
let me take like this
hmm Bishop takes pawn
should have thought a little bit more
about that last that last move okay
let's let's see
you
now this should still be
the right way
and let's go here I could have captured
b7 but I want to keep my Queens central
threatened here do stuff towards the
king where there are many weaknesses
these pawn this pawn
went all in
I somehow just don't want it though
let's step up nice queen is still very
good I would rather take with the rook
if I can let's put a media pressure on
it that move the rook is unprotected to
go here I think I like that move let's
let's continue with this pressure so now
Queen here pressure on everything rook
rook pawn let's keep an eye out for
checks defending here okay and now push
I'm going to push first I want to get
this tempo and then only and then only
capture here rook is pinned is now I
could pivot on this square at some point
the King tries to hide rook takes Queen
takes Queen g6 Queen takes pawn etc this
is this should be winning okay take the
rook and try to hide let's get a check
take this with check another check
another check to defend the pond and
then then get the rook active I'm on
this rook as well okay let's
give a check like this quean a quean
block is not there and now
broke up now let's give this check and
then I guess here
this is not the cleanest approach
add something like to win the Queen rook
okay this is good rook here next could
simplify everything let's check let's
check and then run it here keep them in
the pin for a little bit
get this pawn rolling okay back
determine where we have 571 598 624 678
crest sixty-four okay it's in 29th and
43rd let's go it's Knight f6 guess an
Enzo Indian
okay click Castle maybe I should have
captured that night maybe
so there's no structural damage and we
got that move coming up play d6 my
bishop is a big dummy on b7 I will
likely have to reroute it
reroute them clean on e7 take really
don't want to take hmm all right I'm
doing this to try to
about this pawn
eventually this is going to hit my
Queens defending this in case of night
be five and not too much I could do
about this move let's get the night over
here maybe night on g6 for starters ok
it's ruled out maybe h3 let's go here
let's race this pawn up mm-hmm
I want to keep the Queen's on I think I
think let's get this in my rook is
defended by my bishop
yes
let's go here
would not mind seeing this free up for
this response okay that move I do mind
sing that one scares me
hmm
need to defend that
on my back foot
you
Bishop g4 okay surprised to see the
capture there and get some rooks
exchanged I guess
my queen okay
you
it's a good move
not sure what to do this I've defended
because of a check okay now they're
there defending that I think I almost
mouse slipped there
I want to keep this pawn around
sure how to how to improve here
you
getting the rooks off huh
here here maybe here clean here is just
excellent though maybe my
I think I have to allow this pond to be
captured maybe maybe take this night out
tonight is constantly boxed up by this
pond I really want to sneak in over here
if I can
okay take care first
check I needed to try and keep the
Queens on
I'm gonna try to get it off I have
checks
they're defending that square
Queen is defending this
skies now productive
here I guess
clean here
trying to get here
some checks
hmm diving in
down upon
you
okay love to get here but they're just
not going to allow it
okay I have to defend like this I'm
going to get running for Queen exchange
I think I have to maybe try this but
it's
ask was that a Muslim
I think this is a draw but clock says
otherwise
clock says otherwise
oh now it's now it's lost okay oh okay
where we at 6:14 mythic Verma has 47 the
cable box 4045
not sure where others are at hmm let's
go with E for
native three
TRAI a Lopez exchange
and we'll open it up oh okay
hmm
we'll go after this I'm gonna have
doubled doubled f-pawn soon
can get rid of them
or even need to
won't tell he I want to
I run the risk of having the black minor
pieces clamped down on f4 if I don't
play this it is a possibility at some
stage yes we'll take get expanding I
guess
you
and we take a step up on a light-square
night here I have a fork
hey any crazy bishop moose
a push
this square starts to look pretty
appealing for a night where a king this
is a passer they have a good night as
well but I'm prepared to offset it so
this guy is under control this guy's
kind of free to do some other stuff here
I could also kind of treat this bishop
as if it's a pond kind of linking these
these split ponds
I do have yet this this guy is they're
not they're not working just yet
yeah I guess here
be careful huh that's a strong move here
night here rook here there's a fork
okay may need to go into a pin night
they're here it's gonna be a trick on
this square I'm hopeful that I could
still shed upon and have a still an
active and active King here so we're
seeing this in action right now they
have that move and the rook the pond
doesn't have to take oops
okay maybe I could entice them to take
with the pond it's it's worth check and
do it taking what the rook is best yeah
okay
hope chess I'm down upon
mmm that night moving to defy was very
strong
activate my pieces King up here
right here rock here not sure how did
how to treat this maybe I need to get
the rook off I that record is just too
good and then maybe maybe do something
with my King down on the clock
check didn't even consider that stay
here I guess I keep efore ID up
okay
okay I want to get my king here
yes here
stuff
Bishop there you know
I hear Bishop takes pawn Bishop takes
and bishops going to get there
okay
for this this pond could fall very soon
maybe it thought they'd push I could
take here
this guy so much for my beep um
try to hold this
it's a tall task
I can't even I want to check the king I
can't even check the king though
allowing them to get a an outside pass
are much easier
do something with my night
yeah okay that's that's defending
that's defending everything
you
I was just trying for a second - maybe
can ican I sacrifice my night and it's
the wrong color bishop now now and
squeezed there probably should have
resigned a bit sooner there okay
let's go with c4
50 minutes to go
let's go addy for
b5 let's go trying to get a pawn to e5
okay on on d5 this is my strong point
take towards the center before gonna
come under fire
I wish I didn't lose that Queen sight
pawn I didn't see a solution in Knight
d5 I here is threatened bishop there I
guess we'll go into a pen develop
yes I am getting kicked I'm angling for
C for a bit backward being keto kick
that night away yeah
that was a that was a free move my
opponent gave me there that AAA 5 I
think before Knight b6 you go you go
a5 yourself okay now Knight here looking
at E 5 let's go here it's a big square
I'm giving up this night might jump in
at some point I guess we back up I'm
hinting at this now that this is
defended me v e5 right now ie 5 right
now then run Castle they're trying for
this caveman stuff I have a fork nearby
this is covered with all three minor
pieces let's land the fork I'm still in
this pin are there any checks for my
opponent no let's take here I'm on the
Queen I have rook here let's check and
then Bishop here with a skewer I could
also take that night why not grab that
night
as well
a couple minor pieces versus upon
imbalance they resigned okay where are
we at 666 dangerous number 664 607 20
trying to catch 720 okay where are we at
I'm in third for the team okay let's go
and see four again why not
Kings Indian Kings Indian defense yes
let's go for this I'm keeping my night
off of f3 because I'm thinking about
this advance but not not not anymore
actually you know let's just develop I
think I'm going to take with my e pawn
yeah let's take what the epon this can
be struck out
IG for soon
all right let's step up hinting at a
dark square bishop exchange right now
let's first keep the bishop
a g4 prevent a pin and
I want to stop Bishop f5 actually some
making some preventive moves not going
right in for Bishop h4 anticipating this
advance yes and getting my rook to where
maybe I should have stopped it all
together with a four or four at least
one more move it to an open file take
with the pawn okay my knight is kicked
away oh he's just gonna jump in here is
that the thing
yeah that frees up the white pieces some
the bishop can see and when I challenge
that night how to take you know they're
just gonna jump in there huh how
dangerous is that pawn go home here
tonight okay
step up
my Bishop's covering the rook important
detail otherwise ff4 can hurt me they're
looking at f4 right now let's go here
hit the rook
whoa not expect that
clean here night into this square whoa
they're giving me that square okay I
have this to work with when to jump in
maybe only after kicked keep the rooks
on an open file my bishop how can I get
the bishop laying out there's an open
diagonal rook here
there's no rookie 7 because I take the
night King here
yeah I came there let's just go back for
a second see if I could know that that
would drop the f5 phone huh do I have
something here
let's try let's try this the knight
can't take because of this
okay a lot of things change if any okay
my Rick is going to be challenged soon
I have Brooke here okay
they're in a pin let's go for this I'm
looking at g5
I might be I might be winning
you
here
I get at this point
Queen takes here is hitting with check
hmm okay
it's close to me oh I'm getting the
Queen
at least the Queen let's just get the
clean chief okay 692 seven so K this guy
gotta go fast
let's go for e4 only 43 minutes left
let's go for this c3
it's little
set up
let's go d3 first
this may be nearby
hmm I'll go in for it
protectee five
all right so there
sure on it
taken with the rook
let's go here I don't want to take the
bishop this bishop I need to keep a Pete
a bishop or a pawn here to stop Knight
f4 main purpose the bishop here I take
here this then having to play g3 and
weak in my light squares
it's tough pressure here centralized
with this guy this is going to have some
pressure on it this night could do
something else looking at this and then
winning here
they're Knights maybe then I could jump
in here I guess well they'll hear first
this knight could do something else
where does he go
f3
feels weird
feels weird
we're going to try
get my knight on e5 okay mass exchanges
maybe
I'm hinting at some tactic against the
night I'll take like this I am on the
night now maybe was that was too quick
nice move
the rook the Ponte sigh get the rook so
that they are split the Queen has to
take
oh the Queen takes I have a fork
they resigned poof okay
tough to tell am I on fire
am I on fire I don't know if I'm on fire
who's that back to back wins oh yeah two
wins in a row maybe okay
I guess d5
we're getting a lot of this London set
up very popular
easy to play some fast moves Queen c2
Bishop f5 here unlike in the the other
game
okay still here
and I'm going to back off I'm doing this
so I could try to maintain this pawn on
c4
Bishop is maintained um let's go well so
much for maintaining this point okay
forgive me a chance
they pulled my queen away and then tried
for a quick B three I might not have
been able to maintain
stuff let's jump in here Knight takes
I'll take with the pawn superglue that
bishop in there
yeah they should stay put that's a
strong move
and let me go here and keep this night
right here there's a big battle minor
piece battle over e5 I don't want a
piece to ever really be able to sit on
this e5 square for an extended amount of
time so
try to influence this bishop Queen c7 is
way expecting this yes
b5 my clean does have responsibility hmm
I could take care
let's let's go here first
oh that was a very quick capture so the
a file is not going to open up
huh
I'm gonna take care I want them moved
back I want to be able to move my queen
with a punch and then get ready to
battle on the on the B file actually may
be Queen a5 was better
okay that's how they're defending so
let's take here get on the B file now
let's go here be your queen I'm
threatening this and
okay now let's get to the beef I was
threatening this and stopping Queen a
for some activity I can take the night
hmm
me take tonight
yeah where else is that guy gonna go
okay sneaked my pawn up I'm not sure how
to assess this one
really
we both have some invasive ponds this
guy this guy for white
be file
for up do I want to go with this plan I
don't know I'm just kind of do similar
just copycat game hmm
that move let me see if I could provoke
this and then their second rank is
weakened get my clean right back 283
actually why will I get my clean back to
83
if g3 there's f4 okay Queen there let's
go here the idea to get my rook to b2
and then the structure change we'll both
have a couple pass pawns but mine will
be the more invasive one just to step
away
if ever captured
and if there's ever this pawn break this
rook is gonna be brought to life that
could only benefit me I think not much
action going on here not much tactics
between the the C D and E pawns
okay Queen here one day could hurt me
let's keep going with this pawn I could
put pressure on this guy too
okay really gearing up for g4 I guess
let's go route B to check is nearby
Brook B to check is nearby let's put it
on right now
ah I could have played queen here Oh
take care
oh that was a big mess Queen there Queen
h4 was beautiful
take
I mean it was just I think lights out
oh no I I can just I got this covered
let's just check stay out of this pin
there's no Queen takes pawn here and
then push or maybe here no that would
blunder
hmm rook here is important I got a
different mice my second rank hum yeah
they're all in here what's that move
doing though I just take here five
seconds Oh
another check
huh I'm down on time oh man
Queen h4 right here is winning like on
the spot
ah they played King h3 one move later
I missed it too late too late I didn't
get a second chance go at c5 there's
only 35 minutes left students this is
flying by ah man
and that one's bugging me
it is bugging me
okay I don't don't know too much about
this one but I going I'm going after the
e5 pawn even if this guy falls he's hit
three times now Oh Queen h4 the checks
check the checks check the checks
hmm okay so
parting ways with a pawn guess we'll
take Castle Knight here okay there's
that move
I'm weakening my light-square is quite a
bit with this move
clean here I do have a five or rook move
but I ah Queen there I'm gonna need a
rook move this time now I'm dead
yep f5 too easy I got to keep it closed
the eff out
opening up would be too much I miss
queen of five mmm-hmm this guy needs to
play I guess here it's too easy it's too
easy for white
age six was under fire
yeah that's a nice move cutting honey
well I don't know about that move
actually take here
I'm gonna run I do have the bishop to
block
Queen takes here my king is continuing
to run for his life how many pounds
might down one
that's a good move
you
Queen takes pawn is threatened
this looks nice
the knight is maneuvering
okay
26 if night here feel like the 19 ax
on the other direction could be kicked
at some point this guy could do
something else should probably get out
of this pin soon huh
um
I don't know let's just do something
that's looks aggressive
I really don't I'm not threatening to
take here so there it comes back over
but maybe at some point I am
I don't know there may be some tactics
over here actually let's just go out and
let's just keep going here it's gonna be
ass a corona very soon I don't know
there's not too much I could do about
that I don't think ever taking here is a
wise choice so
my Center will collapse fast
kay bishop hitting my knight i go here
and try it right there oh oh that's
that's nice
here
they take their first okay
here
here
oh my time I think I'm defending this
but my time
Oh
down a full rook
I'm not defending this I had to go no I
get I guess I think I was just losing a
book no matter what there
here in push
yeah
I guess I'll plan for a little bit here
should I
should I
maybe not a tricky night
I'm in a pen
you
down on time ooh aunt position okay 28
minutes left Carlos
meeting berserk
let's go it's c6
so looking for three or maybe a five I
might be on fire
no tick
Oh a queen f5 move was a killer
the mention of castled in that game
okay well that's a big square they've
given up
let's shoot for it
okay that's it it's a big square they've
given up centralized
to keep the night out with b6
that shouldn't be an issue
and my other night
let's maneuver my other night
right here stop rook entry throw a punch
my other Knight wants to be here
control this night
get this night right here even here
at one rakov
wouldn't mind that don't lose her over
Manaka maybe two
maybe two rooks off I'm okay with my
night is very good
hmm
you
okay
my queen is more active I have a better
night let's throw them in a pin
my bishop
let's go for another pin
I didn't see that that was a move let's
throw a check in there
threatening Knight takes pawn and miss
that
on
I could actually kick the Queen King
away from their queen with checks
deflection got all these covered with my
miners
okay back to tournament 842 897 909 944
25 minutes to go hmm I guess a d4 game
let's sneak a d4 game in there
let's go for this normally I try to get
my dark square bishop outside the chain
we're gonna go for a fee and kiddo
okay let's go for this what crest did in
a in our game
early squashed my bishop and I had to
take some time to reroute
I'm just going to leave them sitting or
yeah just leave these pawns setting you
take me defend the bishop
and I'm going to give this a try
actually okay I don't mind seeing a
close on the queenside hmm
how much should I want this position to
be closed
let's try this opening up an F for idea
right now I'm going to say right now
that is a that is a threat
I play E 4 e 4
you
a critical moment here yeah II for
or or
this I'm looking at this Square if
pushed
okay they're keeping me
of that
I don't want to give this square up to
the night
so I just hold my ground I don't know
okay they kept my night out this is the
pawn break
try to get that in and
Queens up yes
let's get this in where do I want my
Knights
here here here
pressure on this
okay
okay do I take and rather
see them capture me let's get this guy
going G file
very locked
I guess get off with the this file here
and I get my other night doing something
what about let's try this get my night
to this square
is hitting with the fork okay that's a
let's let's go here I'm looking at a
sacrifice if they block it yeah
I'm gonna say let's keep the tricky
nights around I want to be able to
control both color squares
and we sacrifice back
let's go at this move
and
No
where do I put both of my nights I'm not
sure
this is my way in possibly so tough
see how to let me get to one of these
two giving up a pond
my other night here maybe I should've
did that right away prove my king a
little bit
I don't know
his tough
on the bishop I'm on the night and I do
something with my King
on the seventh twenty seconds I'm
running out of fuel I've got no more
fuel
yeah their Bishop is there to stop my
pawn mmm didn't find a good way forward
there 20 minutes to go whoo look at all
the points are being racked up thirteen
hundred one thousand eight eighty one
eighty d3 collet
whoo okay 20 minutes
that one yeah I pushed too hard on that
in that last game giving up a pawn just
open up the a file you could sit in that
position you just and I know it's one of
those where I don't know I think white
could try for something in black cast
away
and I tried something and it didn't work
clearly okay we have been here before
very familiar structure and why not take
here and I do Bishop takes Bishop first
I guess now I'm able to take here it's
check
now let's take here actually no Bishop
moves no discovery my bishop right here
and Castle Knight on f2 would be nice
don't know how to get them there though
let's back off now Knight here now we
know how to get them there and this
Knight is defending I'm on the bishop as
well I could remove that night that's
their best piece let's uh let's try to
get rid of that Queen takes Knight here
I have Bishop takes pawn missing
anything no tonight is enormous I'm up a
couple pawns actually clean they're very
active looking move could be fancy or
just go here let's go Here I am in a pin
after all challenge this Knight
right here this Bishop takes Bishop I
have the fork
this rook takes night
Queen closed to trap let's try this
first actually f5
and then Bishop f6
okay
queen is close to trapped
very close to travel it's let's go here
just gonna be flushed all the way back
to see one no f4
you
hmm
I feel like I'm making this extra
difficult for myself for being up for
being up to pawns I'm doing a good job
of making life difficult here can I get
this guy rolling let's get them rolling
see what happens
where's the Queen go see one now Queen
exchange is cool
for my opponent maybe I don't want that
this could be difficult to defend
even on the clock
let's inch up maybe g5 I have a new
square - two squares for my night
let's go here first cut the bishop off
Oh actually they're in trouble now big
trouble the bishop kid doesn't have a
move
maybe they just take here now
you
some trouble
and I guess
and give the check
and then push offering a draw Wow
let's keep pushing
get rid of that tricky guy no really I
would but he's under control for right
now although I am giving him this square
I should just capture that night
okay still winning simplify
the black hater and push through is the
plan
and this should do it only 14 minutes
left they resigned okay poof fourteen
minutes to go how many points can
can you get Grandmaster
cm Grandmaster
have been paying zero attention to the
to the twitchchat here
let's go at the Carroll
mmm Bishop chief for and I'll take
back off you could take
and allow the space
not to be very careful now about
castling kingside
let's put them in a pin Bishop here
Knight here is gonna hurt
this guy needs to stick around to defend
this after this move this is this is a
problem I think for white do I not win
upon in the center
I think I do
don't have to take it right away
actually
I'll go here first this is hit twice
defended zero no pawn to defend Bishop
there
okay they're saving the pond but they're
building up my Center pretty good
should I take this
huh
no if I wouldn't even take it
I'll take it
you
it's scary because I still have to
castle
here
to watch out you know can they stop me
from castling are there sacrifices here
I don't think so run this
Bishop there let's go here I have
this covered may kick my night I also
have f6 if they try to coordinate on g7
so that move to I'm okay with giving up
the exchange
okay they don't want it
let's take this pawn
other up come on the night a little
little more loose
whoa
okay
you
you
how am i stopping Queen f6
it's thinking about this and then here
but Bishop takes Bishop takes it in h6
and the pawn and the Queen converge
maybe this is a move
whoo so active very very active
okay night-night nf5 this took a lot of
time this took a lot of time
you
on my bishop miraculously okay now no
things should be much cleaner clean here
King here and then Queen up six
or a queen exchange a minute five
my night is hit let's go stay active
here pressure on f2 pressure on f2 so
Brooke h1 is not there
clean here okay that move
let's go for
oh this hit the rook and then I have
this square in this square
you
almost forgot the queen is defending
here
want to keep the Queen's Own get to h3
maybe
call tonight block this diagonal bit
let's go here Queen h3
they resigned whoo hi figured they would
have uh they would have still played on
there nine minutes to go only one two
more games maybe
efore facing a caro-kann
huh
a caro-kann maybe not more like a
a weird French
a delayed French or something
okay let's get the knight out of the way
prepare for this maybe maybe
yeah we'll stick with this
and castle
see four or not No
you
um
so look for the h4 move where they go
with the king
making me think they're going to go
clean side
you know
you
but the night here could be pretty
invasive nh5
okay it's been locked up so no no idea
to get the night here
you
hmm okay not ready to jump in here too
six on this push I'm doing this just to
provoke something what is that something
now I could maybe jump in it's a
different story completely locked now I
go here what's happening
that goes back here among this as well
mm-hmm
Knight takes feels crazy
let's try it and you jump in here on
this move restricted this guy has
responsibility very locked how do I move
that over oh I didn't even consider that
that was a move okay I guess I'll be
giving up this and they'll have an
active queen so what's the imbalance of
rook and three pawns versus Bishop and
Knight
Wow okay this guy's not playing yet
oh here knight on f6 one day I'm gonna
want to get my rooks playing um yeah one
day I do want to I do want to do that
put this Knight here first free up my
Queen from this responsibility clean
exchange okay I like this
I guess I'll be taking away from the
center if Knight takes bishop let's keep
this night around some material yeah
let's open the file for the row
connected passers this guy's still not
playing
let's go King I need to need some help
here I could jump back into this square
booth this should definitely be winning
now okay um I keep that Bishop from
getting activated I'll take the bishop
if he goes here same story if it goes
here I keep pushing I don't need this
this Bishop is sectioned off to this
side of the board just keep on moving
they're making up to g5
yeah I'll just leave that sitting let's
push here here promote is the plan ro
can't get to activate it because I have
this 15 seconds
ready to push a threat a couple million
to
all right they resigned can I sneak in
one more game
maybe 3:40 now it's very unlikely we'll
go we'll go fishing for a last game we
can do that we can try to go fishing
against max
let's see
3:30 they could always not resign
you
prophylactic move there stop any Knight
g4 so fat let's still go for it
hint at night g4
maybe
okay yes
there's a hole here on g3
important that I'm able to take on the
square roots check
otherwise I'm tactically vulnerable to
this stuff in this
okay I got nothing better I thought
about this and this
it's not working maybe I play in the
center d5
let's go in the center yeah our opposite
my bishop and it's very indirect a lot
of a lot of stuff in between let's dive
in even if this pond somehow gets lost
this guy should be enormous
Oh remember that tactic I was talking
about there it is now that the Bishop
takes Bishop isn't with check yeah
yep
let's go here take here I have this they
may still do it though
let's see
this one is probably just not going to
finish for the tournament
yes here
King here ISA 'kz
he and f7
I was just for a second thinking that I
could
capture this rope
okay rook takes pawn is is a threat
go here this is a blunder because I
could in the intake here
how they blundered
that's good news would they resign
this is completely winning
but they resign
No
rook takes pawn the pawn is pinned
20 seconds
you
let's grab this pond with Chuck
five seconds this one will not count
Tournament which has flown right by no
stalemates they have plenty of pawns
around
here and then here eventually in my
truck out of the way let's go here first
give the check and then here
I'll just grab a bun and get my king
here okay they resigned back to
tournament finally get to look at the
standings here this thing flew by
Wow
okay final standings crest book chess
club 150 or 1527
top player Rebecca Harris at 126
jebel co second
each me third
Kings crusher
1257
top Berzerk only 98 oper 93
and FM Sean RL 1 2 3 88
to go through these yourself those of
you watching right now
see how the points that are racked up by
all the players
here's third fourth shemot canal
penguin agad meters
Network seventh Eric Rosen then chess
weebs
hmm I wonder how like how close it
really is
how much were these points going up I
didn't I really didn't have any time to
see between games
like every every 10 minutes it could
could have jumped up
like 50 points
huh okay let's see
for
team chest network the cable box in with
69 Congrats cable box
nice
erm ahead 60-58 Pesce nine-year-old
Pesce way to go
56
side
fifty-five
and drew
Andrey something-or-other
54 is where I fell so where was that 1 2
3 4 5 6 or my team 53 / coma another 53
a while now 51
Delina chess
luminous
terminal terminal nice you joined I
didn't see you on a list initially at
the start of the term it may be late
joined nice to have you in there nice a
nice result
sincerity rules I was pointing out
sincerity rules superfast strong player
and very fast with that Mouse for sure
Piro booty
49 Avon Kovalenko 87
Agito Malad 96
Wow
very nice
oh this one's really sticking out
very nice
Blitz rating 1977
still put up nearly 50 points fantastic
result
Wow that was great
the sillim and Jian SAR
all right
let's see the I finished overall
standings one hundred and thirty fifth
let's have a look at I did at the start
of the tournament Willie we looked at
the top
200 maybe we could have a look at the
top 200 see see how some players
finished here in whoa whoa at the start
of the tournament there is only about
not only but there were about 3,000
nearly 5,500 in the end I guess we had a
lot of people joining during the
tournament so this is page one
Rebecca Harris do an all-out berserk
nearly an all-out berserk 95%
Wow in the performance was the
performance rating a 2602
for basically an all-out berserk wow
that's exceptional
all right here is page one
page two
so the top 20
point gatherers for each team
that's uh that's how we get to this
amount right here
okay page three yeah they're just so
close look at I mean eighty-eight is
10th place and then let's say 68 just 20
points off you're in 34th some close
ones here cable box top finisher for
team chest network 69 great showing
let's have a look at your performance
here ah you beat crest nice a draw
against titled wolf draw against legend
2004 I know the cable box to be very
tactically aware from just a couple
games I've played against the cable box
nice nice showing alright let's have a
look still on
crest Brook was their final yeah they
they had nearly 300 pointed over Casey's
team
there's Pesce finishing in 74th let's
have a look at the 9 year old the young
shark 26:35 performance numbers irking
great 26:35 he played against crest as
well and he played against Chagall co
nice and he beat Chagall co on two three
only four losses 79 percent win rate
well done Teja well done great result
all right here's the top 100 Eric Rosen
finishing in 99th 56 points
and keeps jumping on me
here here's another one the performance
here with 55 points 20 to 40 performance
okay there I am
135 kind of performance that I have 2468
71% win rate I had a stretch here of
winds then I was extinguished by my
crest back-to-back losses Hall what was
the one that was tough for me oh this
game here where I had Queen right here
Queen h4 was the winner
would I have one two three four five six
losses okay
still check out some more pages over
coma
how did over coma do thanks again
you know if you're if you were taking
part in this event that it's is this is
a great event and especially if you were
part of a my team here thank you thank
you for being a part of it
I'll have to looked I mean let me go
through these two hundred first why oh
no another one very nice
oh there are more there were there more
games and go back for a second
are these all the games I played
now there was there's still a couple
more games
listed here
I played 24 games
there's still a couple more
or were there no no no that should have
been them all.i last one i guess that
that last one didn't count for the
tournament
all right these are the top 200 I'm not
going to be going through all these
pages so dole
dawna chess
had a nice performance 24:31
you
and another one here in the top 200 at
least new bonus 23:29 performance well
done
very nice 68% win right berserk as well
twenty eight twenty percent berserk Rea
many games
25 games
maybe a late joiner 25 games he did some
berserk II think maybe more games would
be in if you did the berserk and started
from the beginning
anyhow Wow Oh final note here
Oh a lot more players are jumped in
during the tournament but if you'd like
to join the team
this is one way to do it
go here
well this is how you could track track
it down on my profile
here's a link to the team
and you are all welcome to join if you
would like
or when another team battle takes place
this was a lot of fun this was a lot of
fun you know I really like this this was
great
you